the motion is adopted last week Congress
passed a 2.2 trillion dollar stimulus
package needed relief to our nation's
families workers and businesses this is
the biggest stimulus in American history
some of it going directly into Americans
bank accounts and as the kornel virus
crisis continues killing jobs this might
be just the first round some politicians
and policy makers have said that this
extraordinary moment requires a more
extraordinary bailout and one
alternative idea that's been getting a
lot of attention is ubi or universal
basic income now to be clear the
stimulus is not ubi u V Isaac concepts
in which all citizens are guaranteed a
minimum income by the state if this idea
sounds familiar to you and maybe because
you've been following to the Democratic
presidential race Donald Trump said he
wanted to drain the swamp I want to do
something a little bit different I want
to distribute the swamp and during the
presidential campaign you were calling
for ubi for universal basic income and
you called for where you termed a
freedom dividend
now these checks that are going out to
Americans now as part of the stimulus
package do you consider that to be a
freedom dividend included in the
stimulus bill is a one-time check for
twelve hundred dollars for each adult
that earns up to 75 thousand dollars per
year and I think that most Americans
expect that the government's going to do
it again if this crisis drags on into
May or June or even further down the
line but when you were discussing this
during the presidential campaign you
didn't envision a corner virus crisis
you were talking about automation
technology that's right I was arguing
that more and more Americans are going
to get sent home because we're going to
automate away the most common jobs in
our economy from call centers and retail
clerks to truck drivers
and it turns out I shouldn't have been
talking about automation I should have
been talking about our pit that me but
many of the trends that I was arguing
for I've just been sped up greatly by
this pandemic because we all got sent
home at once but not everyone agrees
with Andrew yank connecting these
payments to universal basic income I
think it's a real misunderstanding to
think of this as a form of basic income
or any kind of validation of that idea
or any kind of test of it and you know
in a technical sense it looks like a
basic income
let's mail everybody checks okay people
think of the Gang Gang and the basic
income think about the basic income that
that is core to the concept is that you
get it forever and you know in advance
that you're going to get and that's how
you plan accordingly you live your life
with that expectation exactly so it's an
expected payment and it's a guaranteed
payment and it's a permanent payment and
frankly those are the concerning
elements of it before the coronavirus
crisis it was difficult to imagine
anything like ubi taking off in the u.s.
[Music]
Jason Furman served as deputy director
of the National Economic Council during
the Obama administration it was largely
[Music]
so when you hear people talk about this
in terms of basic income that this is
like basic income do you see it that way
the point but it's a a test of the
notion of basic income in some respects
in any respect to you
it's not like you have to spend money on
this you have to spend money on that you
know that's what you need to spend money
on so so I think it has some things in
common with you be I'm and they go help
inform the debate about the best ways to
provide assistance going forward
compared to many other industrialized
nations the save our workers bill
provides significantly less Denmark
Ireland Britain Sweden and other
countries have passed or are in the
process of passing short-term versions
of ubi for their citizens I don't think
the fight over universal basic income is
about whether or not sending people the
money would it be fair to describe basic
income ubi as a fringe idea of at least
until now well I I think it's here to
stay because after Americans get this
money in our hands in the next two to
three weeks most of us are gonna say
that was a good thing and then they're
going to scratch their chins and say
wait a minute why don't we just do this
all the time
[Music]